I'm so sorry sorry no no it's okay
you're Josh Duhamel mm-hmm I was I was
rushing actually to get to you
yeah okay this is my first first job
very first one well nice to meet you I'm
Josh Brian yeah there's no need to rush
they can't start without me
I hate these things
they ask the same goddamn questions
every day and it's like and I I got I
got a whole lot of great questions
prepared good yeah I just come in here
to clear my head you know a little peace
and quiet before the storm you know I'm
not masturbating or anything just so you
know okay that would be creepy okay yeah
um didn't cross my went once so I'm not
a creep I understand okay good yep
it was great to meet you through the
jungle thanks so much
all right
you Oprah whoa
you are Amen I thought it was back at
the Butler junket am I is Josh ready for
me Oh your Kevin Donnelly oh my god this
is so cool I used to watch you all the
time Brian Butler time hey Brian thanks
for your former support there we've all
the downloader calm that's adorable
is that like a podcast you do in your
mom's basement no no it's not let me
guess you went to film school yeah you
got a few favorite movies course yeah
Godfather
yeah house of Blancas their hot dogs
over here
good talk movies cute thank you looking
really great yeah
production notes the summary was very
cute oh so you have actually I'm gonna
see him probably
how are you wanted to see I'm having a
hell of a day you doing okay
well that's just it you know Britney
you've been oh I know Bethenny why I see
you two all the time right she's leaving
me she's leaving me yeah there was a
little incident with my chambermaid when
I was in a hotel oh yeah yeah I got a
blowjob from the chambermaid Britney
picks up on it she's upset and then she
Springs with me that she's boning our
gardener oh yeah and I was given this
moron a leg up and he's boning my wife
hmm
I'm sorry I asked she's a dingbat but
loves it in the caboose loves what I
loved her in the caboose love sick in
the loves it loves it in the caboose a
face that she was loved shaking bad but
loves it in one minute protein shake
I think that's it I hope we're done this
movie looks terrific it's good to see
you man I wish you all the best
do we have enough you think we got it we
got it okay good Christopher David Brian
Butler are you in snapchat you should be
on snapchat i just sit like 30 egg
whites i feel like a cow are you
talking about how you're gonna take
kevin's job hello okay do a video yeah
yeah ready set go
hi Britney Fox here and just trying to
stay hydrated with my super alkaline h3o
Fierce water you know what nothing is
more sexy than to watch you shill for
water that is sexual harassment okay and
if I cared about that type of thing I
would report you celebrity well fans are
going to love this movie so much thank
you we put a lot of work into this but I
gotta know how do you keep your body in
such great shape I guess I work out a
little bit I mean can I just like no
actually it's just so that's crazy just
let it happen I won't stop till I get
what I want okay there you go
you know I'm getting a divorce right
sound so excited about that um I'm
actually in a really dark place but you
know got to keep a professional hold
down the button yeah you get lots and
lots of use if I'm in the shoot yourself
now he's so old and gross he may as well
die right now I'd be happy Christopher
David here with the buzz and I'm with my
main man Josh Duhamel how you doing
buddy Adam L spaceman man performance of
a lifetime oh wait do you hear that oh
my god just singing this is big news
coming through that's the buzz buzz buzz
of Oscar calling for you buddy and you
heard it here first
on the buzz are you serious I have never
done one of these before
they're so Supes easy all you do is you
walk in the room you get eight minutes
no they get eight minutes because their
national it's a whole patriarchy guys
like you mean we get poor cuz we're
online Decker movie leaks calm I know
you you ran that rumor about Chris Pratt
playing a young Yoda and the Star Wars
spin-off okay I trusted a source
Josh so you're gonna stay on topic I
always do okay so in Transformers Dark
of the Moon Optimus Prime revived
Sentinel Prime with his matrix of
leadership but you so write the movie
that were here to talk about yeah yeah
yeah I was super excited to see me call
spaceman but then found out it was about
baseball do you feel like that might be
misleading no I don't feel like that's
misleading his name was Bill spaceman
lean towards her sports are fun so the
entire Cybertron Japan it no more talk
of dark at the moon okay okay
so in Transformers Revenge of the Fallen
such a dick just gonna be less advice
for me
wish me luck Brian Butler the downloader
calm so so you can stay in till tonight
your other cohorts have been all over
the place Oh got it cool so I watch the
movie it's great and I noticed that this
guy you play really represents that
classic anti hero archetype you really
watch the movie didn't you honestly I
loved it I think you're the only guy in
this whole junkie to watch them campy it
was so good thank you
well he said it was his favorite
interview of the day welcome to the best
sorry sorry this is all I got Brian I'm
not the only one that does this